>>> RUSSIA'S WIDESPREAD MISSILE
ATTACKS ON UKRAINIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE KNOCKED OUT POWER
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT'S NOW MEETING ABOUT 75%
ELECTRICITY DEMAND.
RESIDENTS STILL WITHOUT POWER
CAN VISIT ANY OF UKRAINE'S NEW
INVINCEABILITY POINTS, POPUP
SHELTERS WITH POWER, WATER AND
INTERNET CONNECTION.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY IS HAPPY
WITH THE ROLLOUT OF HIS PROGRAM,
THOUGH THE STATIONS AREN'T
WORKING PROPERLY IN KYIV.
JOINING US IS RETIRED AIR FORCE
COLONEL CEDRIC LEIGHTON.
RUSSIA HAS SHIFTED ITS STRATEGY
FROM HOLDING TERRITORY ON THE
GROUND TO ATTACKING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> THIS IS A REALLY BIG DEAL.
ONE WAY TO ILLUSTRATE THIS IS
THROUGH A SATELLITE IMAGE.
THIS WAS TAKEN BACK IN JANUARY
BEFORE THE WAR STARTED.
THIS WAS TAKEN THIS WEEK IN
NOVEMBER.
YOU SEE HOW FEW LIGHTS ARE
VISIBLE RIGHT HERE.
IT'S KIND OF ANALOGOUS TO THE
PICTURES YOU SEE OF NORTH KOREA
AT NIGHT.
THIS IS WHAT RUSSIA IS TRYING TO
DO TO UKRAINE.
NORTH KOREAS DID IT TO
THEMSELVES.
THE RUSSIANS DID THIS TO
UKRAINE.
THIS WOULD BE KYIV RIGHT IN THIS
AREA.
EVERYTHING ELSE IS BASICALLY
BLANK.
THERE ARE SO MANY VILLAGES OVER
HERE THAT HAVE LIGHT.
HERE, NOTHING.
>> HOW HAVE YOU SEEN THE
SITUATION EVOLVE?
>> THIS IS A LOOK AT HOW QUICKLY
THINGS HAVE CHANGED.
ONE KEY THING IS HOW MUCH WORK
WENT INTO THIS BY THE UKRAINIANS
TO DO THIS.
BY TODAY, THE UKRAINIANS HAVE
THIS TERRITORY, THEY TOOK OVER
THIS TERRITORY.
AS WE GO TO A SLOWER TIME LAPSE,
YOU CAN SEE THAT THE RUSSIANS
WERE ALMOST IN KYIV AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THIS WAR.
THEY ALMOST TOOK KHARKIV, WHICH
IS THE SECOND LARGEST CITY.
THEY HAD THIS AREA IN THE SOUTH,
THEY HAD THE NORTHEAST.
BUT THEN THE UKRAINIANS MOVED
FORWARD AROUND KYIV.
THEY MOVED THE RUSSIANS OUT TO
THE BORDER THIS WAY.
AROUND KHARKIV, BY THE TIME YOU
GET TO MAY, YOU SEE HOW FAST
THEY'RE MOVING IN THIS
DIRECTION.
THIS IS A TREMENDOUS ACHIEVEMENT
BY THE UKRAINIANS TO DO THIS.
OF COURSE, THEY HAD A LOT OF
WESTERN HELP.
IN THE SUMMER TIME YOU LOOKED AT
A LOT OF STATIC MOVEMENT, ALMOST
NO MOVEMENT ALONG THESE AREAS
HERE, VERY MUCH A WORLD WAR I
LIKE ATMOSPHERE.
THEN AS JULY MORPHED INTO AUGUST
AND THEN SEPTEMBER, YOU CAN SEE
THAT THIS IS GOING TO CHANGE
QUITE A BIT.
A FEW RUSSIANS ADVANCES HERE,
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN BY THE TIME
YOU GET TO AUGUST, YOU SEE THEM
MOVING AROUND KHARKIV AND
PROTECTING THAT SECOND CITY.
BY THE MIDDLE OF SEPTEMBER, THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE THIS TERRITORY
RIGHT HERE.
THAT IS HUGE.
AND THEN BY THE TIME YOU GET TO
OCTOBER, YOU START SEEING
MOVEMENT IN THE SOUTH.
THIS IS WHAT YOU'LL SEE NEXT
WHEN THEY TOOK THE KHERSON
REGION TO THE WEST OF THE DNIPRO
RIVER.
THAT IS HOW THE UKRAINIANS WERE
ABLE TO DO THIS.
>> GERMANY IS OFFERING SOME
SUPPORT TO POLAND.
WHAT IS HAPPENING AND HOW
SIGNIFICANT IS THIS?
>> WHAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
THERE, PAULA, IS THE PATRIOT
MISSILE SYSTEM.
THIS IS AN ANTI-AIRCRAFT AND
ANTI-MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEM.
WHAT IT IS DESIGNED TO DO IS
KNOCK OUT MISSILES AND AIRCRAFT
OUT OF THE SKY.
IT CAN ALSO KNOCK OUT DRONES
DEPENDING WHICH SYSTEM YOU USE.
THIS IS BUILT BY THE UNITED
STATES.
THE SAME TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY IS
USED BY THE ISRAELIS IN THEIR
IRON DOME SYSTEM.
THE GERMANS WERE GOING TO BRING
THIS SYSTEM INTO POLAND SO THE
POLES COULD BE PROTECTED IN
THEIR PARTICULAR AREA, BUT WHAT
THE POLES WANT TO DO IS THEY
WANT TO MOVE THIS SYSTEM INTO
UKRAINE SO YOU CAN ACTUALLY
PROTECT THIS ENTIRE EXPANSE OF
UKRAINE.
YOU WOULD NEED TO SET UP PATRIOT
SYSTEMS IN PLACES LIKE THIS IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THE MAIN CITIES
AS WELL AS MAJOR INSTALLATIONS.
THAT'S HOW THEY WOULD WANT TO
PROTECT THESE AREAS, BUT THEY
NEED NATO SUPPORT AND NATO
APPROVAL TO DO THAT.
>> WE KNOW VLADIMIR PUTIN VERY
GOOD AT PROPAGANDA.
WHAT'S HIS LATEST MOVE TO
CONVINCE PEOPLE THINGS ARE GOING
WELL?
>> ONE OF THE THINGS HE DID
HAPPENS TO BE ON RUSSIAN
MOTHER'S DAY IS HE MET WITH
THESE MOTHERS OF RUSSIAN
SERVICEMEN STATIONED IN UKRAINE,
SOME OF WHICH WERE APPARENTLY
WIDOWS FROM PREVIOUS
ENGAGEMENTS.
HE'S REALIZED THERE IS THE
POSSIBILITY OF DISCONTENT AMONG
THE RUSSIAN POPULATION BECAUSE
OF WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO THE
TROOPS, FAILING TO PROVIDE
LOGISTICALLY FOR THE TROOPS.
HE'S BROUGHT THESE LADIES IN TO
CONVINCE THE GENERAL PUBLIC THAT
HE'S A CARING PERSON, THAT HE'S
CARING FOR THESE SOLDIERS.
OF COURSE, THE FACTS ON THE
GROUND ARE COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
AND THOSE